picture this  it is 2050 and together we have built a  climate neutral society solar and wind  energy has replaced fossil fuels our  cars buildings and factories use clean  energy and we breathe clean air  new jobs have come with modernization  and green technologies our cities are  greener and we are better prepared for  heat waves and floods  our forests and natural areas have grown  and wildlife has flourished we've  averted the worst of the climate crisis  we are back on track sounds too good to  be true  in europe we are convinced it's possible  if we start now we can make it in europe  we have a plan the european green deal  to become climate neutral and to grow  our economy at the cop 26 in glasgow we  will call on the world to raise ambition  and take action that will lead us to a  better future